بعد اشعر بن القتال بين قوات فاجنر والجيش
الاوكراني في مدينه بخموت اعلن قائد قوات
باجنر اللي بتقاتل بجانب روسيا اعلن امس
السيطره الكامله على المدينه وظهر عناصر
في مقطع بيرفعوا رايتهم على اعلى نقطه في
المدينه وبدا الكرملين يهنئ بعد مرور
الجانب الاوكراني في الاخبار ويقول هم
صحيح دخلوا المدينه لكنها مو تحت سيطرتهم
وبين الاخذ والرد وبين النفي والتهنئه
شفنا على تويتر دعوه لزياره فنائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي ديمتري استغل الفرصه
ودعى الماسك لزياره المدينه من بعد
السيطره عليها طبعا ما ننسى انه ماسك من
الاول كان دخل على خط الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
فمره عمل استطلاع على تويتر اقترح فيه خطه
للسلام بين روسيا واوكرانيا نطلب منهم
التصويت عليه وهذا عمل له ازمه مع
الاوكران هذا غير خدمه كمان ستار لينك
للانترنت اللي هي تابعه له واللي زود فيها
الاوكرانيين وهذه عملت له
[موسيقى]
على العموم ماسك للاهل مرض على الدعوه